i've become online friends this past
year with an astronaut
like an actual astronaut who's been on
the space shuttle in the space station
it annoys me because this astronaut
friend can always win any conversation
by starting a sentence with
well when i was in space what a jerk
what a super cool jerk i love pretty
much anything space
mars perseverance amazing plans to build
a moon station
let's go not everyone feels that way
though
some people think that the money spent
on space exploration could be better
spent right here
on earth that's a valid concern there
are certainly enough things here on this
planet that could use some help
but i don't think it's an either or
situation
i think we can explore space and make
things better
here science is science whether here on
earth or
408 kilometers in the sky you know maybe
we can learn how to fight climate change
better to save the planet
which reminds me a long time ago my wife
and i were told we needed a new roof in
our house
roofs are expensive we just moved
instead
i don't know why i thought of that
solving unique problems in space have
already provided solutions to other
problems here on terra firma
from water filtering technology to
digital thermometers
gps cochlear implants cat scans all
invented as part of space programs
oh and if you use a smartphone thank an
astronaut
just not my astronaut friend i've
emailed him a bunch and he said i should
stop sending him messages
so he's probably pretty busy doing space
stuff